للجماعات والاحزاب الكرديه الايرانيه
المعارضه وجود قديم في اقليم كردستان
العراق وذلك منذ ثمانيات القرن الماضي
خلال الحرب العراقيه الايرانيه وكانت
بمباركه صدام حسين لكن مقار هذه الاحزاب
وقياداتها لطالما كانت بمرمى الاهداف
الايرانيه
وقصفها منذ ذلك الوقت مضره من تخليها عن
نشاطها المسلحه وانشطتها المسلحه وتركيزها
فقط على العمل السياسي بالرغم من انها
تمتلك اسلحه ولديها مقاتلين ومعسكرات في
اقليم كردستان العراق الا ان الاحزاب
الكرديه الايرانيه لا تستطيع الرد على
القصف الايراني والسبب هنا مانع وحاجز من
داخل الاقليم نفسه اذا التفاهم بين هذه
الاحزاب الكرديه الايرانيه والحزب الحاكم
في اقليم كردستان بزعامه مسعود برزاني يمص
على السماح بوجود هذه الاحزاب مقابل عدم
انخراطها في عمل عسكري ضد جيران الاقليم
لتفادي زعزعت علاقه الاقليم مع ايران
وغيرها
وتجمع روابط تاريخيه بين اقليم كردستان
العراق وكردستان ايران في شمال غربي
البلاد يتحدث سكان المنطقتين اللهجه
الكرديه نفسها وكثر من بينهم لديهم اهل
اقرباء من طرفي الحدود بين البلددين
[موسيقى]